the campaign trail in 2019 when
interviews at the local hospital are
repeated for the candidates Facebook
page Rosie Duffield one Canterbury for
labor in 2017 by just a hundred and
eighty-seven votes to keep her seat she
needs to spread her message online my
team have done the odd adverts and I
think they know sort of who's looking at
it and who's not I don't get involved
with that thread of things that much but
it probably is really useful yeah I'm
sure social media is a really key thing
in the selection that hopeful attitude
is in sharp contrast to the Tory
campaign in Canterbury this is the
London office of Westminster digital a
social media agency making video for
Conservative candidate and a Westminster
digital venues Facebook's advertising
tools to make sure the videos reach the
right audience we talked it to people
that care so people near that roundabout
might get an extra push because they
care right it's it's the traffic that's
annoying them these entrepreneurial
20-somethings say they're working for 50
conservative candidates in this election
but to put it in blunt terms thing can
you win someone a seat of course I think
so absolutely I think this is the this
is the way to reach people and I think
what what we're seeing especially now
for example if we look at Canterbury
again a lot of people when she goes and
meets and I said oh you've got the dogs
you're the lady with the two dogs
beautiful dogs because we've put those
videos out whether that's true will be
put to the test on Facebook Edie Widders
runs Canterbury's 36,000 member Facebook
group which played a crucial role in
2017 was a hive of activity it was a bit
of a surprise for everyone just how much
it became a political battleground this
election is all boiling down to social
media people are spending hours and
hours reading the thoughts and opinions
of their neighbors on social media and
it's going to influence their decision
edie hosted a Facebook live hustings
with Rosie Anna and Lib Dem candidate
Clem
if there is a crisis they can actually
pay people back she's an outsider in
this race which looks like a straight
fight between labour and the
Conservatives anyone looking in the
comments could see plenty of strong
views about them they say that all
politics is local Cantabria digital to
role amantha Sky News is we want to put
five